avec nos trois drôles de jeunes filles
qui sont avec nous ce matin d'un coup
d'un seul j'ai pris un coup de vieux là
clarisse élu n'aura vous attend quelque
la soute les trois cinquièmes mais je
crois oui c'est ça on salue le collège
andré lallemand de pouilly en auxois qui
nous regardent peut-être et des copains
et des copines à qui vous avez dit que
vous étiez ce matin sur france 3
bourgogne franche comté oui ouais sont
sûrement cours ah oui c'est vrai
évidemment vous avez une dispense louis
bon par contre là vous n'aurez pas de
dispense pour me dire de quoi vous
voulez me parler parce que je crois que
vous avez mis en place un projet qui
vous tient à coeur c'est bien sa classe
oui alors notre projet s'appelle un
cahier un crayon
il consiste à aider les enfants cette
année ceux du tchad
donc nous récoltons des affaires
scolaires neufs donc règles comme
cahiers crayons et ensuite on les envoie
ouais au tchad d'accord en fait c'est
une association c'est ça devra en fait
oui c'est une association elle s'appelle
solidarité laïque elle organise ceci
chaque année n'est pas dans le même pays
donc en fait on récolte les fournitures
dans notre collège et on les dépose à
dijon avant fin décembre et ensuite
l'association allez recueille dans toute
la france pour à les emmener au tchad
dites moi vous qu'êtes toutes les trois
copines nora comment ça vous est venue
l'idée de nous parler de ça à nous et
bah c'est une de nos amis qui nous a
montré dans un manuel d'histoire
un document qui parlait cette
association est elle nous a dit qu'elle
y avait participé il ya deux ans dans
son école et on a eu envie de continuer
pour encourager les enfants pour leur
prouver qu'on pense à à leurs
difficultés à leurs problèmes leurs
moments difficiles ils pourront penser à
nous ça nous donnera du courage de
penser que des gens pensent à eux
ouais alors clarisse et enora dites moi
un petit peu ce qui ce qui vous touche
dans ces enfants là dans l'eau parlant
qui chantent au tchad alors on a
beaucoup de différences par exemple le
confort nous on a une vie de luxe par
rapport à eux
eux n'ont pratiquement pas de table
chacun et sont parfois 60 par classe
alors que la norme serait de 25
[Musique]
j'imagine que ça touche aussi la ba oui
parce que nous en début d'année on a
tout le temps plein de petites choses
pour décorer les cahiers et tout ça et
aussi le fait de savoir que nous
on aura récolté bas après c'est eux qui
vont les avoirs bas ça fait plaisir ça
fait quelque chose de sensible à cette
différence tant rêver oui surtout pour
les filles cas beaucoup de lui dans le
monde qu'il faut la cuisine la maison
qu'ils font à manger et ça nous ferait
plaisir que les filles aillent à l'école
pour pour qu'elle apprenne pour leur
métier plus tard et c'est peut-être plus
facile pour aller à l'école pour elle ça
veut dire quoi concrètement vous vous
organiser comment les filles allez on va
commencer par clarisse alors au mois de
juin on s'est mis d'accord avec monsieur
bouvet notre principal pour pouvoir a
graffé un mot derrière la liste des
fournitures scolaires pour informer les
parents de notre récolte donc en la
agrafées et comme ça ça permettait aux
parents de quand il allait faire les
fournitures scolaires de leurs enfants
bad d'acheter un cahier ou un stylo elle
sera leur éviter de faire un
aller-retour
on voit d'ailleurs une journée à l'école
au tchad
j'en ai pas si ordinaire est pour toi et
line après la rentrée on est allé sur un
site pour commander des fiches pour
aller mettre sur des panneaux
d'affichage dans le hall du collège pour
expliquer le tchad avec des photos où ça
ce site c'est ce qu'on voit là c'est ça
oui très belle très belle photo en tout
cas il ya pas mal de choses
deezer c'est la récréation sac est
l'heure pour vous la récréation le matin
bon alors il va falloir patienter encore
28 minutes à pour être un petit peu ma
création je vais te faire travailler un
or à toi et bah en fait on a récupéré
des cartons qui avait dans le collège on
les a on a collé des affiches un peu
comme ça dessus et puis entre midi et
deux ans les matins dans le hall pour
que les élèves puissent déposer leurs
fournitures à l'intérieur d'un joli
projet ça
we wept firme je suis tout seul sur le
plateau je vais pas vous applaudir mais
mais franchement moi je suis très très
fier parce que déjà vous avez trois
jolis sourires
c'est très agréable je suis sûr que les
parents sont particulièrement fiers de
vous vos frères et soeurs aussi en a
beaucoup
bah un petit peu ouais combien de frères
et soeurs j'ai deux frères les prénoms
bas evans frère jumeau et puis à julian
mon petit frère d'accord tu sais que
j'ai à la réalisation de cette émission
ce matin le papa de
deux triplés alors toi c'est les jumeaux
il ya mieux non non frères et soeurs et
oui un petit frère et le ghana d'accord
il une grande soeur mélina voilà parce
que trois mois après quand on va
repasser l'émission ils vont être super
jaloux et ça va être encore un drame un
drame à la maison donc nous on n'est pas
là pour ça j'ai juste avant de se
quitter parce que on a rendez vous avec
un grand garçon qui a envie de nous
faire jouer au monopoly vous connaissez
le monopoly preuve que c'est toutes les
générations
j'ai envie de vous demander qu'est ce
que vous voulez faire plus tard on va
commencer par toi à moi j'aimerais
travailler dans le droit être juge des
affaires familiales
ah oui c'est très précis voilà les
auront pas quel âge j'ai 11 ans d'accord
11 en cinquième mais juste des affaires
familiales pourquoi tu veux faire ça
parce que j'aime bien quand ça file doha
j'aime bien c'est carré cé carré mais
j'ai remarqué c'est super carré alors là
vous êtes toutes les trois
genia je me demande si on va pas vous
faire venir plus souvent parce que vous
avez très bien toutes les trois pour toi
et les moi j'aimerais être être
vétérinaire m'occuper des animaux comme
les bêtes
oui d'accord mais donc tu vas bébé y'a
pas de soucis que des animaux la maison
ah oui quoi donc j'ai un chat un chien
un lapin elle bat avant j'en avais
d'autres mais c'est quoi les petits noms
de ces bestiaux la haye dit mon chien
le mas c'est mon petit chat max mon
lapin et j'ai deux chiens chila away
c'est une vraie ménagerie quoi garder
bonne chance aux parents et avec les
enfants ça va quand même être un peu
rock'n'roll
et puis pour toi alors bah moi
j'aimerais être institutrice de cp
pourquoi pas j'aime bien les enfants
bon ben c'est parfait moi je vous aime
bien aussi donc voir rester avec moi un
petit peu